2020 will see the release of some of the
most anticipated games including some
excellent looking Nintendo switch
exclusive titles from original sequels
to ports here are some of the Nintendo
switch games we're excited to see
release in 2020 Tokyo Mirage sessions
fuses together a crossover between the
Fire Emblem and Shin Megami Tensei
series the single-player RPG game was
originally released in 2015 for the Wii
U and is now releasing on switch
complete with a brand new story and
battle elements that aren't in the
original version Tokyo Mirage sessions
is set to release on January 17th Animal
Crossing New Horizons is the fifth main
series entry in the Animal Crossing
series this well-known franchise has you
arrived on a deserted island as you
gradually craft and build until the
location is teeming with the bustling
community of talking animals highly
anticipated and one of Nintendo's
flagship series animal Crossing's New
Horizons will release on March 20th not
much is known about the next entry in
Square Enix is bravely series other than
it's slated for release sometime this
year the game will have a new story and
characters and promises to have that
same field with the bravery series is
known for ninjalah is a first-party
multiplayer action game from Nintendo or
eight players either locally or online
park or across buildings in arenas to
battle it out in a mixture of ninjutsu
and bubblegum combat the release date is
coming up soon as ninjalah has a
tentative spring release date No More
Heroes 3 takes suda51 s designer talents
and in the world of the No More hero
series developed by grasshopper
manufacturer No More Heroes 3 will bring
back the action-adventure hack-and-slash
style in the single-player game as you
once again follow the antics and journey
of Travis touch now 2017 had a surprise
hit in golf story and the game will now
have an exclusive direct sequel on the
Nintendo switch in the form of sports
story similar in aesthetic the indie
multiplayer adventure game will have you
go beyond just golfing as you embark on
quests and play interesting takes on
classic sports making friends and rivals
along the way sports story is slated to
release in mid 2020
[Music]
Xenoblade Chronicles was a highlight for
many during the Nintendo Wii era and now
the game is ready to make a triumphant
return in the remastered definitive
edition for a Nintendo switch return of
the story chronicling The Adventures of
Shulkin fiora
when xenoblade chronicles definitive
edition releases later this year there's
a lot of exciting ports exclusive
content and original games coming out
this year for the Nintendo switch a
Nintendo fans will have much to look
forward to let us know what you're
excited to play on your switch this year
or what other games you hope may be
announced as the Year continues
[Music]